[Music]
welcome back it is time for this week's
pet project
lori herron joins us from the nspca and
she brought along someone who needs a
safe and good home this is whisper lori
it's whisperjc yes whisper is
a really sweet 10 year old
tuxedo cat what we call the black and
white cats
and and whisper has a condition that we
see a lot
in cats that come into nevada spa it's
called stomatitis it's an inflammation
of the gums
and it is a condition that requires a
quarterly injection that actually we're
going to pay for
so it has helped some other stomatitis
cats get
homes and we know there's a lot of
people out there right now jsp that
have some financial insecurity and we
want to make sure that doesn't stop them
from
giving beautiful whisper a home so again
whisper is 10 years old and for her
stomatitis condition
will pay for the medication i've been
watching her
off camera and whisper scenes very calm
very relaxed tell me more about the
demeanor of whisper
she's sweet she's purring right now
she's really a sweet young little girl
10 years young and oops i guess she's
not that sweet
she saw herself on tv she saw herself on
tv so she got excited
if someone's watching they already have
a cat and they want to get a second cat
how does that process work can they
bring the cats down to meet
so we don't do meet and greets for the
cats but we do recommend
um and cats like whisper if they'll get
along with other cats which she will
we are our fabulous adoption counselors
here
we'll talk to you about what's a good
fit for your home
so that we make sure that when the
adoption happens that the
that it's going to be a good fit for
both you and the animal
beautiful thank you so much lori we
appreciate it fun fact lori was at my
wedding back in 2007.
so it's always good to talk to you
laurie now if you're interested in
adopting a pet go to the nevada
nspca.org or call them at 702-870